Christ is risen so for those who were so
for those who were here last night you
heard father Stephen speak and it's been
a few times that I've talked after
father Stephen it's always a bit
daunting to speak after father Stephen
but it's also very strange because in
the last conference I gave where we were
speaking together I felt like he was
also in the same mind space as I was
that he was looking at the same sources
that the same fathers and and bringing
his ideas together in a way that I found
exciting and felt you know went well
with what I'm doing and so as father
Stephen talked to us about this
ontological transformation the the
salvation as an intelligent illogical
change which comes through the
Incarnation but also that shows us the
source of reality down is that better
yeah a little bit all right okay and so
that is what interests me mostly is
because I am an artist
and I'm someone who looks at imagery who
looks at narrative who looks at patterns
what I try to do is to try to show
people that the stories that we have in
the Bible that our liturgy that our
rituals that they're not arbitrary that
they're not just these arbitrary things
that we engage in that will somehow
bring us to heaven or whatever you how
you conceive it but rather that the
stories that we find in the Bible and
the traditions that are brought to us
through the church they're actually
helping us participate in reality itself
that they're showing us how reality
works and how we can participate most
fully in reality and so the mission that
I've kind of given myself in life is to
help people to the extent that it's
possible see how what this looks like
see that it is not just arbitrary that
that there are these powerful beautiful
patterns which underlie our tradition
and though
patterns are talking about something
they're talking about our experience our
experience in our relationship to the
infinite God and how those all of that
comes together in the wonderful amazing
moment of the Incarnation and how the
Incarnation is that the source of
everything so what I want to look at
today is hesychasm does who here knows
what hesychasm is all right so it's
definitely not the majority
so hesychasm is it is a technical word
to talk about the mystical tradition of
the Eastern Church the mystical practice
and the ascetical tradition but it's a
way of also viewing the human person the
the hesychast the christian mystics
describe the human person in a certain
manner and my contention my as I see the
way that the hesychast describe the
human person I can see that that
description is the same thing or the
same pattern as the architecture of the
church as the iconography that we look
at it's the same pattern as the stories
that we find in the Bible that all of
these things come together and are just
one more manifestation of how reality
lays itself out so it's going to sound
abstract at the beginning but as you'll
see it slowly land into very practical
reality I hope as I go through this and
so you could synthesize pretty much all
of the Christian mystical tradition in
this one phrase that Christ uttered oh
it's not there okay you just put it up
yeah it's right you told me to do that
and then I didn't all right
and so to to speak of the heart that's
especially what I'm going to try to
speak about what are we talking about
when we talk about the heart what is we
use it in colloquial language we talk
about the heart even even the most you
know the most bland kind of
non-denominational Christian will say
you need to accept Jesus in your heart
you know I thought who knows what that
means
but they have an intuition of the truth
in that in that sentence there's an
intuition about this notion of realizing
something about your heart that is that
is that is still even though it's kind
of deformed and strained it still
connects to something intuitively right
and so the way that we need to get come
to understand reality let's say is to
understand it as macrocosm and microcosm
and this is how the many of the Church
Fathers talk about reality st. Maximus
the Confessor and a good way to
understand it the notion of the center
is a good way to see that the tree is a
good example of how this works it's this
idea you can understand it as a fractal
reality that there are if you look at
how a tree is made every branch of the
tree is the same structure as the tree
itself so every time there that there's
the basic tree but every branch is a
little tree and then every branch of
that little tree is also a little tree
and as many branches as there will be on
the tree every single branch of that
tree will be a little tree so every
single branch is slightly different but
they all follow the same pattern that
the the tree itself has okay and so that
is how this notion of macrocosm and
microcosm is going to work and as we
look at it you'll see how the the the
Church Fathers interpret it and so the
Church Fathers
the church the church father especially
Sam axe with the Confessor really
emphasizes this idea the idea that the
human being is a microcosm of the
entirety of the cosmos and a way to it's
very important to differentiate the
terms that we're using one of the
problems we have today in the modern
world is because we've given our mind so
much to technical understanding and to
scientific interpretation when I use
words like cosmos when I use words like
heart you think of you think of just you
know like a valve in your body when you
think of heart and when you think of
cosmos you think of all these planets
and-and-and stars in order to in order
to enter into the mind of the Father as
in order to enter into the mind of the
the Bible and our narratives we have to
come back to our experience and
understand that human experience is the
first experience there it's the first
point of departure for any knowledge any
understanding we are a being in a body a
conscious being that is looking out and
the world is presenting itself to us in
this field of perceptions that we have
and so we need to try to enter back in
it's not that hard to do that it's not
that hard to do that because we live in
that space we live in that experience
but it we've been so used to thinking
that somehow technical descriptions of
reality which are accurate they're not
inaccurate but they are secondary to our
experience okay so when I'm going to
talk about the heart I'm going to talk
about the heart in terms of something
that you experience as you're living in
the world and the beating the beating
the beating pump is part of it but
that's not the that's not the totality
of it and so say Maximus talks about he
says the the entire cosmos consisting of
the visible and invisible things is man
and man consisting of body and soul is
cosmos for the intelligible things
participate to the substance of the soul
as the soul has the same reason
as the intelligible ones and the
sensible things bear the image of the
body as the body is the image of the
sensible things
the intelligent elavil intelligible
things are the soul of the sensible ones
the sensible things are the body of the
intelligible ones it's a complicated
quote but if you if you if you if you
look at it simply it doesn't say that
much which is complicated what it's
saying is that you are made in the same
way as the entire cosmos that the way
that you're constituted in terms of the
fact that you have an invisible aspect
to you you have something which is not
cannot be quantified cannot be measured
you know what we call the soul what we
call the the the the the spiritual
aspect the intelligible aspect of our
existent that is also that which is how
the cosmos is made and now this is
something which I know like I said for
the technically-minded
it is so difficult to understand that
because we're so used to thinking only
in terms of quantifiable phenomena and
measurable things you know all the
science and all that and and and like I
said there's nothing wrong or inaccurate
about that but as as we move further in
time and even as scientists start to
come to the limit of their capacity to
analyze the world they're hitting a wall
they're hitting a wall which is the wall
of the intelligible x' the qualities of
things why do we see why do we see unity
in anything why do we why do we think
that something has an identity you can't
you can't measure the identity of
something of anything anything in the
world
could be a cup it could be it can be a
person you know the covenants of the cup
you can't measure it because the cup is
made of a lot of different details it
has parts so why do we think that those
parts come together and become one thing
what what makes that happen
what makes things that are multiple
into one the scientists are looking
around and they're realizing okay this
world is just a quantum field they call
it it's just a field of potential
whatever and so how does it jump from
that up to John or Joe or a tree or they
can't account for those jumps in
qualitative reality they just they just
can't because those are they're
invisible and so if you look at even
recent recent physicists some of them
are toying with what they call the
anthropic nature of the cosmos which is
that they understand that the cosmos has
to somehow be shaped in a way for
consciousness to exist in it and some go
even further and say that consciousness
is an inevitable aspect of the cosmos it
has to be without consciousness there
are no qualities the world is just flux
right without name you could say it you
could use the Bible way to say it you
could say without let there be without
without a mind that says let there be
light let there be this that thing
doesn't come out of the potential it
doesn't come together okay it sounds a
bit we'll keep going hopefully it'll
hopefully it'll come together as I as I
go further and so what's important to
understand is that st. Maximus and the
Church Fathers and whole of Christian
tradition they place the human being at
the center of this whole thing that's
why man is a microcosm because that's
what we do we are the ones who give
meaning to the world man is man is the
vehicle by which meaning enters into the
world and without meaning it's not clear
what actually exists and so st. Maximus
talks about man as being the pinnacle of
creation that man was created on the
sixth day the
last creation because he was meant to
bridge the invisible bridge the Essences
bridge the names bridge that the the
invisible meaning with the material
world and so as we as we look at this
notion of the heart saying Isaac the
Syrian says apply yourself to entering
your interior chamber and you will see
the celestial chamber for it is one and
the same door open on the contemplation
of both the latter of this kingdom is
hidden inside you in your soul wash
yourself of your sin and you will
discover the degrees by which to ascend
and so this is this notion of the heart
this notion of the heart is starting to
appear the way that the Christian
mystics will talk about the heart as
being the if you think about what I what
I told you about this tree that has a
branch which is the same shape as the
tree you can see it this way the human
being plays the same role in the world
as the heart plays in the human being it
has the same structure right so the
human person has a structure the cosmos
has a structure and in the heart of the
person there is that same structure it's
like an embedded like an onion it's like
this embedded these embedded centers one
into the one into the other and we see
it like it's not just in the Church
Fathers there's a there's an amazing
quote by saint paul who says for it is
the God who commanded light to shine out
of darkness who has shone in our hearts
to give the light of the knowledge of
the glory of God in the face of Jesus
Christ and so this this text is
suggesting that there is a relationship
between God saying let there be light
and not only the Incarnation but the
light which shines in our heart the
light which enters into our heart and
that light is the
this this image of God that we're
talking about like this is the this
conference is supposed to be about what
is this image of God that the saint
gregory of nyssa some of the father's
talk about this divine spark that that
in in the heart of hearts of hearts of
hearts you know you know hidden
invisibly in the person is a spark of
God and as you remove the veils of the
heart and as you enter into that central
space then you encounter your own origin
you encounter your own origin you
counter as much than your own nature as
a human being but you also come into
contact with your very Creator who is
hidden in the heart of heart of hearts
you could say so say Maximus talks about
the human being as this all containing
workshop that about binding all together
in himself so as into God so as much at
no sorry is it into man yeah as much as
he has also been given the power of
unification thanks to his proper
relationship to his own different part
so as much as the human being unites his
own parts into his heart right he
doesn't use the word heart but the
Father's will slowly start to use the
word heart more more MORE exactly so man
was further brought into being as the
last of God's creatures because he was
supposed to be a natural link between
all creation mediating between the
extremes through the elements of his own
nature and so that this is what I was
telling you about
that the human person mediates the
extremes of the world the human person
unites in them the invisible and the
visible and it's like it's not
complicated to understand because like I
told you human beings are the ones that
give meaning to the world animals don't
give meaning to the world we are the
ones studying the animals the animals
aren't the ones studying us we are the
ones who are studying nature the nature
isn't isn't studying us and so we are
the human person has a central place to
play in in
any meaningful arrangement of the cosmos
even if it is even if it is a scientific
description behind that scientific
description is this fact that human
beings participate and in participating
in the the meaning of the world they are
acting in the image of God they are
enacting the the their nature which is
to be that link between heaven and earth
so when I when I think about this it's
funny because my mind actually goes to a
very famous Confucian saying and many of
you probably have seen this this saying
before if there's righteousness in the
heart there will be beauty in the
character there's beauty in the
character there'll be harmony in the
home there's harmony in the home there
will be order in the nations when
there's order in the nations there will
be peace in the world and so you can see
in that image this embedded microcosms
you can see how it starts in the human
heart that if the human right that we
have this saying right that that the
just upholds the world that the Saints
are the are actually the pillars of the
world without Saints the world would
fall apart that with that are Saints who
pray and who are in communion with God
are actually holding the world together
they are actually acting as that link
between heaven and earth and if I say it
like that it sounds so it sounds
mystical and kind of esoteric and weird
but I mean just think about it in your
own very personal life you know what
happens when your own life is somehow a
little centered what happens when you
know you're able to to move away from
your sins what happens when you're able
to be in communion with the people
around you because you are able to be in
communion with God it's the the effects
are dramatic your family comes together
and then the community comes together
around those people and you always if
you know any church that is fruitful and
that is growing has those people in the
church
doesn't even have to be the priest but
you have to have those people that are
are working on doing that and then they
end up being magnets and and and
ordering the world by their own
transformation you know and so it's
there it's not something which is kind
of esoteric it is actually how reality
works and so so we have this notion of
this Center and one of the things that
evac'd has actually actually but what
this is an intuition this notion of the
center of the heart of this seed you
know of the the pearl in the field you
know the the smallest seed all these
images that Christ uses I had this
intuition a long time ago about that
about this idea of this divine spark
which is hidden in the world which is
hidden in us you know which is hidden in
creation and the one thing that always
bothered me even when I was becoming to
orthodoxy is that there's also this
other tradition which is that all evil
also comes from the heart and so this
idea that that not only good comes from
the heart but also all our all the
badness of our self and I didn't
understand it at first there's the one
there's the one famous one famous verse
that Christ talked about when he says
but those things which proceed out of
the mouth come from the heart and they
defile a man for out of the heart
proceed evil thoughts murders adulteries
fornications thefts false witness
blasphemies those are the things which
defile a man but to eat with unwashed
hands does not defile a man and so I
really struggle with that at first
because I was like how do you reconcile
those two ideas because I could see it
right I could see this kind of
concentric space even in the church
that's how the church is built right you
have the altar and you have the chalice
and in the you know you have that you
have the the church itself and then in
the church you have the altar and then
in the altar you have the actual altar
and then on the altar you have the cup
and then in the cup you have this
invisible
transformation which is the thing which
brings us into communion you know it's
like so even the actual structure of the
church is the same structure as as the
sinks are like why then this where's
this idea of the evil coming out of the
heart and so there's there's some
there's some really even here's this one
alright so st. dia del casar for the key
he says there in the heart is Satan but
the key the key there is in the second
part of his quote that's where I started
to understand it is that there's there
in the heart is Satan though he is not
at its core and there's another amazing
quote also by st. Gregory Palamas
and he says thus when God's grace does
not dwell in man then the demons make a
nest at the bottom of the man's heart
like real snakes and they never permit
the heart of man to desire the good and
so sang-doo Doukas uses the image we're
talking about we're talking about
spacial space I'm an artist I talk in
spatial terms okay so st. Jude okis
imagines the center and he says I'm
still saying that in the heart of hearts
is that seed but in the heart it's it's
it is these embedded microcosms so the
heart is the image of the man is the
image of the cosmos so the same thing
that happens in man is still already
there in the heart in the heart already
is the same structure it's just like
embedded into itself and so it's not he
says it's not at its core so it's like
the heart has a first veil you could
call it right and that veil could you
know inhabit that's where those first
evil thoughts kind of come out of and
then they come out and and and and it's
it's even even when I started to to
think of it in terms of the cosmic
aspect is when I started to understand
it it's like let's say that I wanted to
change dia dukas's citation and I can
make it cosmic instead of saying that
person what if I said something they're
like they're in the garden is Satan
though he is not at its core that that
doesn't surprise us right because we
know the story right we know the story
and then we can if we look at the image
let me put up the image right if we look
at the image we can see exactly that all
right so there is that there's the
center there's this access in the middle
and there's that first little veil
around the access right so right there
in the garden is the tree and around the
tree is the the snake and that's the
same that's that's the image that dia
doukas of photo ki is suggesting is how
our hard works and so you can imagine
that in the heart right in the center of
a person and I hope by now that you
don't think that I'm talking only about
the little pump there's anybody who
still thinks that you're going to be
very very confused when I say that in
the heart is as if there's a little
heaven and a little earth in the heart
already you know and that's what st.
Gregory Palamas tends seems to seems to
suggest when he says if the grace of God
is not there is not active in the heart
then at the bottom of the heart all the
snakes right think of the Leviathan now
at the bottom of the cosmic ocean you
know that you've got a little Leviathan
inside your little ocean in your heart
right so it's these structures they
imagery brings it all together so that
we can see this this pattern and so a
good way to understand it if we look
again at the the story of creation and
the story of the fall we can see what
happens we can see it in that story
because we have to understand it as a
separation st. Maximus talks about how
man's purpose is to unify heaven and
earth that man's purpose is to unify the
intelligible z-- with the the man if the
the the sensual world that's our purpose
and so the the problem happens when they
when there's a split when it breaks
apart right
and we see that right there in the in
the story of Genesis because it starts
with it starts with a desire to be God
right so you've got this split that's
not that wasn't that wasn't the that
wasn't what we were meant to be we were
supposed to be united with God but we
were supposed to do it in that
incarnational that that unit that
capacity to unify the two together but
Adam and Eve have this desire to be God
they they tried to go up st. Maximus the
Confessor talks about what he calls sins
of the right hand and sins of the left
hand you could call sins of the right
hand the sins of of heaven you could
call them something like that in the
sense that pride self-sufficiency it's
this rising up like pulling you know
putting yourself up above things and so
then they reach up to become God and the
opposite happens right they fall into
shame so they move from pride to shame
in in a second
right in one second they move from
pulling themselves up and then falling
down into this sense of shame and then
sense of shame is the the real real
realizing that you need that you're no
longer in the heart because what do they
want they want a covering they want to
cover themselves right they want that
veil they want it they're moving out
already they're moving out of the heart
and and when you move out of the heart
you encounter just like when you move
out of the the holiest place of the
church or if you move out of the temple
in the Old Testament you find veils and
you cover yourself and you move out and
it happens right away in that first
moment in the story of Genesis where you
see that yeah you see the structure of
everything right there
all right
and so this is probably send Nicodemus
is later has he casts but I think that
this this description is a a very
beautiful description which which kind
of brings everything together in terms
of what I'm talking about
so he says we must therefore keep in
mind that as the center of a wagon wheel
has a certain number of spokes going out
to the circumference of the circle and
returning to the center where they meet
so also is the heart of man like a
center where all the senses all the
powers of the body and all the
activities of the soul are united and so
then this is this basic idea that I'm
telling you about this idea of the
center and periphery so a person has has
extensions right we have thoughts we
have feelings we have we have also of
our body we have desires we have all
these elements about us and the purpose
of the christian mystic comes to be to
enter into the heart and by entering
into the heart just like if you think of
a wheel what happens to the spokes of
the wheel when you get closer to the
heart they get closer and closer
together and then finally they fuse into
the center of the wheel and as you move
away from the heart the further you get
from the heart the further and further
away are the spokes from each other as
they are from the heart and so father
father Steven yesterday talked about how
talked about this notion of moving away
from being in tune on being right this
moving away from being into not being is
exactly that because it's not that
things stopped to exist nothing stops to
exist right god that's not how God
created the world things don't stop to
exist but things will fragment will will
start to dissipate will start to fall
apart and you can see it you can imagine
that a wheel that that becomes so big at
some point you from one spoke you can't
see the other one you don't even know
that it exists and that's how someone
can become just a passion right someone
can be completely taken over by a
passion or completely taken over by an
aspect of themselves where they think
that that's all that they are because
they're so far from their heart
that they can't see anything else all
they can see is that one passion which
has led him led them far far away from
their core all right
and so this is
this is a I can this is like an image of
a person you could say the Church
Fathers use different words and they're
not it's not a system this is not
systematic but I've taken I've taken
some of I think what are the best words
and the best concepts to help us
understand the basic structure of the
person and so I kind of separated into
the structure of the person the
operation of the person is what you do
and then the actual even the actions of
the body because we do live in a body
and so the way that the father's
understand the person is that at the
center of your Center of Center you know
there is you have the grace of God in
you you have a you have a you are in
communion with God you have the capacity
to to enter into the life of God and I
know father Steven yesterday he used the
word deification and some people in the
crowd just got I went to see some people
jump you know and that's a word that is
not does not if people are not afraid of
in the Orthodox tradition you know that
if it's properly understood we don't
believe that we become God by nature
that we lose our human nature but that
we that the purpose that God created us
for that is why God created the world
God created the world so that we could
participate in his life because that is
the love that he has for his creation is
to enter into a true communion like a
man and a woman become one body so - God
unites himself with our soul and that is
that that is the the ultimate goal of
everything okay it's important to have
that or else if we don't have that idea
then we we run into trouble later on
when we start to understand what
religion is about because if we don't
know that that's what it's about then we
end up calcifying in our rules as father
Steven talked to us about that we need
our rules we need them but we need to be
careful to think that this is not about
legal legal legal moral problems it
really is about transformation of the
person to enter into God and so the the
father's talk talk
about capacity that we have which is the
noose which is the intellect it is the
capacity to directly into it the
presence of God it is above and it's
hard because we don't very often have
access to that anymore our world is the
is the enemy of this capacity the entire
modern world is there to - to extinguish
the noose as much as possible so it's
very difficult tonight we kind of
sometimes we kind of have to take it on
faith for a while but then we do have I
think that everybody sometimes does come
in contact with the news sometimes they
don't know that that's what's happening
they we have these sometimes these
intuitions these little little support
you know these little wake up moments
when you you kind of see things come
together you can you can see all of a
sudden you you feel like you can see God
work in the world how God's will
manifest itself and often lasts like a
fraction of a second sadly you wish to
get hold I mean I that's what the Saints
wanted to do they want to hold on to
that and kind of make their life into
that little those little moments but uh
so that is that that is the the highest
aspect of man then we have our thoughts
right our imagination or will all the
things that modern person thinks is the
somebody of a person let's say like the
father's will tell you that you are not
your thoughts that you are not your will
that you are not your imagination you're
not your desires you know those are
those can participate in your being but
if you identify with those things then
you're going to be on one of those
spokes which is moving away from the
center and if you if you go too far then
at some point you become possessed you
you act you know they use images of
demonic possession you become possessed
by that thing because you think that
it's all that you are and so they talk
about how we have also a desiring
capacity and in irascible capacity
capacity to be annoyed to get angry to
to to to you know to be impatient all of
that can can be also as part of our of
our our makeup you could say and so the
hesychast
they have a
obviously there is the participation in
the Liturgy there is all that but more
particularly they they developed a
spiritual practice and the the spiritual
practice is meant to lead to this
theosis this deification that is the
purpose and what it does is it uses
operations of the soul like attention
like memory like invocation to enter
into the heart and now you have to you
have to think about those things they're
not obviously they're not arbitrary this
idea of attention what what happens when
you pay attention what is that we use
another word we call it focus right what
does that mean right these means exactly
that it means concentrating needs to
concentrate is to move towards the
middle
that's what attention does and so this
notion of being attentive is is a
integral part of the mystical practice
so what are you attentive to you have to
be attentive to the other parts of
yourself because you see them go wild
all all all around you you have to be
attentive of what's happening and then
you have to remember God now think again
about that image think of that wheel
right what makes because all your parts
that wheel all the spokes there's
nothing wrong with them
there's nothing wrong with your thoughts
there's nothing wrong with desiring
nothing wrong with your body there's
nothing evil about any of those things
they only cause a problem when they
forget right when they forget what
they're attached to
and that's memory memory is the capacity
to stay connected to something when
you're in a distance from it so you
remember your origin you remember
something
that you didn't even participate and you
remember as you as you remember and and
the old obviously the ultimate act of
memory is communion which is let's say
perfect memory where even though we are
eating bread and taking wine even though
we are in a church in the 21st century
we the memory is so perfect that we are
completely also united to that which
we're remembering that we are completely
we are also participating in that moment
where Christ gave his body and his blood
we are where we're united to that and so
these are the these are the the
faculties you could say an invocation is
the same the invocation is a is what's
called the Jesus Prayer people who is
here has heard of the Jesus Prayer there
may be most people now okay so most
people now infer the Jesus Prayer and so
that the Jesus Prayer has several forms
it's it's a the the most complex form
Lord Jesus Christ son of God have mercy
upon me a sinner but the father say that
it can be contracted to a point where
it's only Jesus or only Lord Jesus
Christ depending on on the situation and
so it is ultimately an invocation now
this is if you think again about this
this wheel right think about this idea
also of the of the Invisibles in the
Bible and in any traditional way of
understanding that is what names are
names are if you name wench once
something has a name it has a being if
it doesn't have a name it doesn't have a
being okay a name brings things together
I know that's probably a little hard to
that's further hard to get okay
so Adam names the animals and by naming
the animals he participates in their
capacity to have meaning and so we we
have to understand that unless something
has some meaning
it it let's say it's splinters right
it's splinters into infinite detail once
you have a name well you can experience
it you can experience it in in your life
you can spirits of the difference let's
say I always tell people like if you're
sitting on a bus and you're surrounded
by strangers right and then someone you
know walks into the bus what happens
where does your attention go right that
person will glow will glow that person
will shine it will they'll stand out
like a beacon everybody else is just
gray and then all of a sudden that
person stands out right and that's
that's the that's because you know their
name okay and knowing their name is not
just a technical thing it means you know
who they are you you know their being
you you you have encountered them you
have been at least somewhat in communion
with them to a certain enough so that
you recognize them right and so the this
notion of invoking a name is really this
capacity to be in communion with
something to know something is to invoke
a name you know and a this goes this is
so kind of understood that that even in
like popular superstition if you go to
like if I lived in Africa for several
years this idea that you should not
reveal your name to certain people was
very important because if you reveal
your name to the wrong people then they
have power over you because they know
you and so this this this is a very very
deep it's a very deep understanding of
how the difference between something
which has a name and something which
doesn't is that you have this this
communion with it and so the invocation
of of the name of God like we do in
prayer the invocation of Christ is this
call to be in to be in in communion with
what ends up being our own origin what
ends up being the very source of our
being which ends up being the very thing
which we are aiming towards which we are
we which we are going
towards hoping to live in the fullness
of the image of Christ and then and I'm
wondering if people are concentrated if
I've lost everybody watching everybody I
like hmm interesting I won't ask who's
Lawson who's concentrated I will not ask
that all right so I'm gonna go quickly
over this last part but I think it's
important to to mention and because the
the the hesychast
also had a physical practice right and
it was the repetition of this prayer
often it was a looking down either at
their center looking at their heart
sometimes looking at their navel and
then they would also time their their
prayer with their breathing and they
would talk about entering into the heart
and compressing even the air as you
breathe in compressing it and pushing it
down into your heart and I want to talk
about this a little bit because it has
been extremely demonized in the early
20th century in the late late 19th early
20th century this practice was demonized
even within Orthodox circles and I think
that the reason why it was demonized was
because of an infiltration of this
modern way of thinking this technical
vision of the body where you know it we
we don't understand that these embedded
microcosms that I'm telling you about
the fact that all these structures fit
into each other also includes the body
the body is not excluded from that the
body fits into that pattern the body has
to pray as well and so the this idea for
example if you think of just breath it's
not it's not that hard to to the the
father's talk about how inhaling is
gathering of attention and exhaling is
the dissipation of attention right but
that's actually true
I mean what's the first thing we do when
we're born right what's the last thing
we do right okay and think about anybody
think about when you're who here ever
who most people have experienced it who
has experience concentrating on
something and realizing that you're
holding your breath right this is not
this is this is this is there's nothing
arbitrary about the practice that the
father's developed that we do in fact
concentrate when we hold our breath
right and the the expiring of the of the
we've even used would expire to talk
about dying the the the the expiring
exhaling is also linked to death and to
dissipation in our experience in the
human experience if you think about this
idea of gathering so now think of this
wheel all right think of the wheel that
I told you about think of the spokes and
think of this notion of gathering all
those spokes connecting them to the
middle bringing them into the center
right now think of the creation of Adam
how was Adam created so Adam God
gathered the dust of the earth I
gathered into one place and then what
did he do he blew air into Adam so
that's that's the shape of a human
person that's it right this gathering in
and this breathing in that's what makes
us that's what makes us human and it has
to do with this capacity to attend right
the capacity to remember and then to be
that unification of heaven and earth
all right I think I'm gonna skip some of
these here hi let's see
all right this is so this is that when
we talked about this notion of
dissipation so lies this is Sanger Misa
liability to death then taken from brood
creation now remember this image of
heaven and earth okay
so taken from the material world let's
say was provisionally made to envelop
the nation created for immortality it
enrapt it externally but not internally
it grasped the sentient part of man but
laid no hold upon the divine image this
is really important by the way to
understand this the problem of this
notion of the the fall and what exactly
is the fall the the the mystical
tradition of the East has always
contended that the image of God that
that spark never went away the image of
God was always active in the human
person and the fall consisted in this
veil that that came about around that
divine spark and this these these
multiplicity of veils that kind of
covered this spark so that we forgot
that it was there that we were too far
on that wheel and we forgot our origin
we forgot what it is that actually made
us live and we we are became obsessed
with all these things on the periphery
all the desires all these and so then he
talks about how the sentient part
however does not disappear but is
dissolved disappearance is the passing
away into non-existing butts dilution is
the dispersion again into those
constituent elements of the world of
which it was composed so here you see
this fragmentation that we talked about
right and if you think about it that is
also what death is right death is
decomposition that's what death is death
is you have something a person and it's
holding together it's a bunch of mush
but it's kind of it's kind of holding
together and then at some point it
starts to break down and the elements
that constitute it start to to pull away
from each other and that's
that's death that's death physically
that's also death spiritually it's the
same same process where your thoughts
your desires your peripheral elements of
yourself they start to pull you apart
and they rip you and everybody is
experience that come on right
you can even experience it literally at
the same time you can have to to code
contradictory desires pulling you apart
and you're like how is it that I can
have these two desires they don't seem
to fit together but they're there
they're there happening at the same time
and you're like okay I'm literally being
ripped apart by by my desires you know
and everybody I think everybody has
experienced that so here's this image
that I that I told you about of the
creation of man and the breathing in
right and so you can imagine Krotz you
can imagine in that little moment you
cannot imagine Adam as a heavy cast and
he's and that breath is coming from
Christ and that and and Adam is saying
what is he saying he's saying Lord Jesus
Christ he's saying that's his he is
invoking he is invoking as he is
receiving that breath he's recognizing
his Lord as he is being created and you
can even see in his gesture that he is
acknowledging Christ as he is being
created
here I'm gonna let you read these so
alright so here is sent Hezekiah's of
Sinai this is what I'm talking to you
about in terms of the wheel this wheel
this distraction so it starts by
suggestion
then comes attachments our thoughts mix
with those evil spirit that those are
the evil spirit then there is Union two
kinds of thoughts hold Council and
design the plan for sin to be committed
then comes the visible act the sin this
this if the spirit finds itself in a
state of attention and sobriety and by
contradiction and invocation of Jesus
Christ prevents the imaginative
imaginative suggestion from developing
it does not have continuation so in this
quote which you have also is a very very
powerful link between the cosmic and the
personal this is something that people
really struggle with too when they when
they read the father's I think but once
you understand the idea of the human
person as a microcosm all this sudden
this whole problem of demons becomes
less complicated because you know the
idea that there is a cosmic version of
your passion you could say that their
cosmic version of of your sin and you
mingle with that when you're when you're
moving toward in that direction and you
know there's a cosmic version of it you
know why because all of you are gonna
have the same experience so if all of us
have the same experience of sexual
desire or of thoughts of control over
others or of pride or all of that and
there's a pattern to that experience you
can describe it the Church Fathers
describe it and we recognize it right is
because this because there is a cosmic
version of that and we participate in
that by being microcosm so there's a
link between our sins our passions and
the the principalities you could say the
the the the cosmic forces which are
there and are pulling us or pulling us
as well
all right
I got too many of these too many things
that the fathers have said all right so
okay so now hopefully ten minutes
all right hopefully most of you have
kind of followed me in where I'm going
so my contention at the very beginning a
long time ago I know my contention was
that this structure this idea this wheel
this this this this relationships of
center of memory of attention of
dispersion all of that that's the
structure of reality it is not arbitrary
it is not just personal that's how the
world works okay so hopefully I can I
want to show you a few things that will
help you to see that it's it's it's the
it's there okay so I want to look very
quickly at the story of the prayer at
Gethsemane so and they went to a place
called Gethsemane and he said to his
disciples sit here while I pray and he
took he took with him Peter and James
and John and began to be greatly
distressed and troubled and he said to
them my soul is very sorrowful even to
death remain here and watch and going a
little further he fell on the ground and
prayed that if it were possible the hour
might pass from him and he added and he
said Abba Father all things are possible
for you remove this cup from me yet not
what I will but what you will and he
came and found them sleeping and he said
to Peter Simon are you asleep could you
not watch one hour watch and pray that
you may not enter into temptation the
spirit indeed is willing but the flesh
is weak and again he went away and
prayed saying the same words and again
he found them sleeping for their eyes
were heavy and they did not know what to
answer him and he came the third time
and said to them are you still sleeping
and taking a rest it is enough the hour
has come
the Son of Man is betrayed into the
hands of the sinner's rise let us be
going see my betrayer is at hand
and so look at the image the image helps
you to see what I'm talking to you about
and so there's a mountain at the Mount
of Olives so this is this structure
right this is the this is the mountain
which goes up to the top of the mountain
which is that place where God and people
meet right every time you see a mountain
in the Bible you have to remember that
that it's that's that that's the place
where heaven and earth meet it actually
literally is the place where heaven and
earth meet is at the top of a mountain
right it's this is this is based on
human experience it's not a it's not
it's our but it's not arbitrary because
it's actually what if you go you know
the experience of seeing the sky but the
higher you are the closer you are to it
you know and so Christ leaves the
disciples below and he tells them to do
what tells them to be attentive I'll use
that word instead he says watch be
attentive stay awake don't be distracted
don't sleep right in Christian symbolism
sleep is always akin to what death right
don't sleep and then he says you know so
that temptation does not come to you and
you think it's very strange all those
things are actually very intuitively
right but there's kind of strange that
all those things that kind of brought
together but they're they're exactly
right if you understand what I what I'm
talking to you about so he leaves these
multiple all these disciples on the edge
and then alone he goes up and what does
he do he submits to the Father right he
he accepts what he is there to be he
accepts what he is there to do you know
and he doesn't do it without difficulty
he doesn't do it without sacrifice he
doesn't do it he does it in tears but
that's what he does so he becomes you
know he's for our sake he was he's
obviously the logos doesn't change but
for our sake he shows it that he is what
he's there to be that that he is
entering into the space that he is meant
to be his he's already entering into
that space where he will be sacrificed
and so you have even have this
constellation of heaven which comes to
him which is amazing you know so you
have he goes into this the mountain goes
up to the top goes into that central
space and the disciples on the on the
edge they are not able to stay attentive
they're not able to stay awake and then
he received this consolation so it's
it's it's a cosmic version of that story
you have this scent this central space
which he goes up to you have this margin
on the side with this multiple people
and they have to attend all right let me
show you one more so I mean you two
seconds to try to see what I'm talking
about here okay so now in this image we
have the heart itself we have this cave
in the middle of the image right and
then in that image we have that seed and
every time you see Christ represented as
a child remember that it also is there
to manifest to us this notion of the the
Christ hidden in creation as well
so here's Christ hidden in this cave
just like Christ is hidden in us just
like the the divine logos is hidden in
the heart of heart of hearts of of the
world and of our souls we see the this
beam of light that comes down from
heaven remember st. Paul who talks about
the light that comes down into our
hearts so you see this light which comes
down and then already in the heart they
have their animals already there in the
heart so those animals are that they're
there that's there's that structure
there's that structure with the the star
above and then in the heart you have the
animals that are there kind of like this
first Vail around around Christ and then
if you look at it big if you look at the
bigger sense you have this gathering in
of the shepherds and the wise men who
are being gathered in and
coming now towards Christ to worship Him
and then above you have the spiritual
principalities that are participating in
this and then below you have the
distraction so there is st. Joseph who
is being distracted by the devil the
devil is saying yeah you know you should
do now I'm not so sure about this and
he's and he's here and he's he's
wandering so there's a reason why we
also we put them at the bottom of the
icon and so this image becomes a another
microcosm of the same of the same story
and I could I could go on like I always
give too many examples but there are so
many many many examples everything has
the shape let's look you look at the
pattern of the holy schema right there
is the center of the Cross there's the
crown of thorns around the center just
like those animals were around Christ in
the in the cave you know just like that
first veil then down at the bottom you
have you have death you have the
ultimate sleep
the ultimate distraction and then at the
top you have the announcement of the
king of glory all right the same with
the church the church has the same
structure then it's more it's more of a
mountain structure we have the altar
like I said you have the cup you have
the community inside the cup then you
have these veils and veils until you
reach the narthex where we are there to
be distracted we could add the church
hall which we are allowed to be somewhat
distracted in the church hall right as
we kind of move out towards the towards
the outside and so I hope that it's
especially I hope that with the last
example that I gave you it landed a
little bit more into reality but this is
true of anything if I have a cup the cup
has a heart there's something which is
making it a cup it has a heart right and
it also has parts which could distract
it and if I break it into pee
and I fragment the pieces then we lose
the memory of the heart we lose the
memory of what that is is for what its
identity is and that is just everything
is like that everything has a everything
has a core has an identity has a logos
everything has parts and those parts
have to be connected to the middle have
to remember it that is just the shape of
like I said it's the shape of reality as
we experience it as we engage with the
world as we are conscious beings which
are looking out and engaging with the
world so hopefully that little
meditation will get all your gears
rolling and yeah thank you for your
attention
[Applause]